Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim
und heute ist der siebzehnte September zwanzig zwanzig und ihr ahnt es schon oder habt's schon gelesen oder wisst es eh ganz intuitiv wir setzen unsere kleine Corona Berichterstattung äh.
In unserem zunehmenden Maße unangemessen benannten Special Corona Weekly derzeit mehr ein Bye Weekly, aber äh verzeiht es uns, wir,
Titel aus. Na ja, auf jeden Fall Pavel ist wieder mit dabei. Pabel Meier, hallo Pabel.
Ja, zwei Wochen sind vergangen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche und.
Wir haben ein wenig gerätselt was man denn jetzt eigentlich Neues erzählen kann und.
Sind ein wenig übereingekommen, das ist ja nun endlich mal Zeit wäre vielleicht den Blick auch ein bisschen mehr aufs internationale Geschehen zu richten, zumal,
werden natürlich auch über Deutschland noch reden äh werden, aber so insgesamt sich alles so wenig, ja, das eiert so rum, habe ich so den Eindruck, also so nichts wirklich
ein außergewöhnliches, nichts wirklich außergewöhnlich beruhigendes, aber auch nichts außergewöhnliches, beunruhigendes
damit wir euch nicht damit langweilen, dachten wir uns, schauen wir mal ein wenig in die Welt, denn da ist ja doch einiges los, also für uns
Ist hier schon so eine gewisse Corona Normalität eingetreten, würde ich fast mal so sagen. Ähm das nicht überall so.
Kann man nicht sagen, also es entwickelt sich sehr, sehr unterschiedlich, aber wir.
Haben jetzt fast die Grenze weltweit von dreißig Millionen Fällen
erreicht äh so und täglich infizieren sich weltweit dreihunderttausend Menschen neu und sechstausend sterben äh im Moment,
täglich, das ist so ja dass äh so die Bilanz äh für die Welt und bei ähm.
Den absoluten, also komulierten Zahlen liegen die USA vorne mit sechs Komma sechs Millionen Infizierten bei,
dreihundertachtundzwanzig Millionen Einwohnern, aber ja vierzigtausend
infizieren sich in den USA noch pro Tag neu, wobei dort der Trend jetzt langsam rückläufig ist bei den Neuinfektionen
aber bei den Toten sieht's auch nicht schön aus in den USA sterben pro Tag etwa tausend
Menschen und das ist relativ konstant der Trend. Also da ist noch kein wirklicher Rückgang zu sehen und das ist wie wir sehen werden eine relativ hohe Zahl
mehr sozusagen infizieren sich am Tag eigentlich nur in
mit etwa hunderttausend Menschen gerade am Tag, aber Indien hat halt
ja viermal so viele Einwohner wie die USA, so relativiert sich das. Kommt aber auch auf ungefähr tausendzweihundert Menschen, die pro Tag in Indien sterben
Brasilien ist dann auch relativ weit vorne mit insgesamt vier Komma vier Millionen infizierten äh und mit
dreißigtausend neu infizierten pro Tag, aber auch leicht fallend und mit rund achthundert Toten am Tag auch leicht.
Fallend so und das letzte ist jetzt noch vielleicht bei den großen äh Russland äh mit hundertvierundvierzig Millionen Einwohnern
sind etwa fünftausendfünfhundert am Tag. Russland hat auch so ist in der zweiten Welle drin und es sterben dort etwa hundert Menschen am Tag steigend
allerdings so, aber wie man schon sieht
ganz unterschiedliche Entwicklungen und Phasen äh so. Und ansonsten ja kann man sagen.
Peru, Kolumbien, Mexiko und Südafrika, die auch zwischenzeitlich nicht gut da standen haben, aber mittlerweile deutlich fallende,
Zahlen, so kann man festhalten, wenn man jetzt mal den Blick ganz in die Ferne schweifen lässt.
Ja. Ich habe mir, ich gucke mir das gerade mal äh äh an die äh Länder, die du äh erwähnt hast, was war Peru, was war Peru Südafrika und was war das dritte.
Kolumbien.
Kolumbien. Ähm Kolumbien Mexiko, warte mal, das rufe ich mir hier nochmal ganz kurz auf meinen äh Monitor
Weil ich find's ja immer ganz interessant, dass man gleich mal in die relativ zur Bevölkerungssaal äh zunehmen. Insbesondere.
Wenn man mal die EU als Ganzes nimmt, ja? Und dann ja.
Relativiert sich natürlich so einiges. Also von den von dir genannten äh Staaten steht da tatsächlich Peru
quasi ganz vorne und ähm vor Brasilien, Kolumbien, also Südamerika auf jeden Fall
kein guter Ort, vielleicht mit der Ausnahme von Uruguay, dann kommt schon äh die USA mit hundertzwanzig
Ähm neuen Fällen pro Tag äh jetzt in so einem im sieben Tagesmittel natürlich, aber halt relativ zu äh einer Million Einwohner. Und Indien liegt so gleich auf mit der Europäischen Union, ne
und Russland so mit Mexiko und Südafrika dahinter und was ich bemerkenswert finde ist China.
Hat nichts, ja? Also China ist komplett raus aus dieser ganzen Berechnung.
Irgendwo unter ferner liefen ja.
Die haben's einfach äh nicht nur geschafft, das schnell in den Griff zu kriegen, sondern sie haben's vor allem bis jetzt dauerhaft geschafft, ähm die Zahlen extrem niedrig zu halten, was ich für eine ziemlich bemerkenswerte Leistung halte.
Auf jeden Fall, also für eher das große Land, wie gesagt, neunzigtausend Fälle insgesamt und es scheint da auch nur geringfügig hochgekocht zu sein, so zwei, drei Mal, aber,
alles ja.
Die die kämpfen das ja auch, aber gleich gleich total äh nieder, ne? Also wenn's irgendwo gehäufte Fälle gab, es gab, glaube ich, einen äh ein Picking, mal einen Ausbruch und so äh da sind die dann einfach gleich äh.
Mega hinterher, ne.
Aber die gehen da auch auf eine Art und Weise ran, wo man was man wirklich nicht hier haben möchte, somit hatten wir,
bis hin, dass äh dort äh sozusagen Leuten, die
gegen Quarantäne verstoßen, dann die Tür zugenagelt und verbarrikadiert wurde von in der Wohnung von dem Team und andere Dinge, also es ist schon ja
Ja, sie sind da schon ziemlich krass.
Ja halt keine Toten. So und ich meine wenn man dann anschaut so jeden Tag, was hast du gesagt? Tausend Tote pro Tag in den USA ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Da kann man sich über Terroranschläge schon irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr aufregen, weil die haben im Prinzip jeden Tag so ein,
Terroranschlag. Also ein Terroranschlag in über den man normalerweise fünf Jahre oder fünf Tage in Dauerschleife berichtet hätte und alle fünf Jahre nochmal ein Rückblick im Fernsehen kommt, mit wie's schlimm es doch damals war. Das haben wir jetzt quasi so täg.
Ja. Ja. Ist natürlich, wie gesagt, nicht immer schwer vergleichbar, weil bei dem einen, wie gesagt, ist halt Intention da, beim anderen
eher nicht so, dass es halt eher so die Kategorie Naturkatastrophe, sage ich mal.
Oder irgendwo mit dazwischen, insofern, aber ja ähm.
Das ist auf jeden Fall äh ein Ding, aber es wäre also so chinesische Verhältnisse möchte ich trotzdem nicht bei uns. Äh.
Nee, das äh wollte ich mir soll ich herbei wünschen. Nur trotzdem es hätte ja auch genauso gut sein können, dass äh auch China in irgendeiner Form wieder von irgendetwas heimgesucht wird, was sie nicht in den Griff kriegen und dem Schein zumindest derzeit nicht so zu sagen.
Definitiv nicht, ja. Wenn man jetzt äh nochmal nach
Europa ein bisschen reingucken und so ja äh insbesondere Spanien ist halt äh äh gerade, dass das Thema
äh mit der massiven zweiten Welle und äh da ist die Besonderheit, dass die.
Neuinfektionen höher sind als bei der ersten Welle im Moment, also mit vierzehntausend Neuinfektionen pro Tag.
Gerade in in Spanien.
Zum Vergleich, es ist das zehnfache von dem absolut, was wir haben und gut, sie haben jetzt etwas mehr als die Hälfte, also es ist dann immer noch so rund bis fünf bis sechsfache
an an Institz aufs ganze Land gesehen, äh so. Was allerdings auch ähm.
So man dann sehen muss bei den bei den Toten,
ist auch in Spanien sieht's nicht so schön aus, also da sterben im Moment hundertfünfzig Menschen pro Tag mit auch einer stark ansteigenden Tendenz, also
Spanien ist halt voll drin, wobei man auch sagen muss, dass bei der ersten Welle, äh ob,
wir ungefähr tausend Tote pro Tag haben. Das heißt, wir haben auch da das Phänomen, dass jetzt bei den Neuinfektionen, obwohl die höher sind als bei der ersten Welle äh sterben halt
deutlich weniger Menschen, also vielleicht ein Achtel oder so, als als bei der ersten,
Welle und das sehen wir fast überall. Frankreich.
Läuft halt auch grade eine massive zweite Welle mit Neuinfektionen höher als die erste Welle auch mit zwölftausend Neuinfektionen am Tag und äh,
Ja da sterben fünfzig Menschen am Tag allerdings bei der ersten Welle waren's zwölfhundert pro Tag, die dort gestorben sind, also auch.
Also Frankreich sogar nur weniger als ein Zehntel sagen, als bei der bei der ersten Welle. Aber wer weiß, vielleicht zeitlich verschoben.
Kann noch kommen, aber es steigt dort nur langsam an und ähm ja you cay.
Hat auch eine massive zweite Welle mit.
Neuinfektionen, die so zwei Drittel vom Höhepunkt jetzt der ersten Welle erreicht haben, wo auch viertausend Menschen sich am Tag infizieren und.
Steigt stark an, äh aber auch da sehen wir äh sagen zwischen der Zahl der Toten,
äh in der jetzigen Welle und äh der dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle äh einen riesen Unterschied, also bei der ersten Welle waren's zwölfhundert am Tag, die gestorben sind. Aktuell sind's fünfzehn.
So
Was nicht heißt, dass es nicht in den nächsten zwei Wochen äh sagen noch anziehen kann, weil wir wissen, dass die Zahl, ja die Zahl der Toten, dass das, dass die Wochen äh hinterher äh hängt, äh teilweise sogar Monate.
Ähm in in vielen Fällen. Ja ähm.
Und dann ich meine eines der schlimmsten
Länder in Europa oder vielleicht sogar das schlimmste Land bezogen auf die Einwohnerzahl ist Belgien, die mit elf Komma fünf Millionen Einwohnern jetzt die massive dritte Welle haben
so mit.
Ungefähr genauso vielen Neuinfektionen pro Tag oder fast so viele wie, wie in Deutschland, also zwölfhundert am Tag.
Aber sehr stark ansteigend aber auch hier im Moment nur vier Tote pro Tag und es waren halt vierhundert pro Tag in der ersten Welle.
Ja und in Deutschland nur zum Vergleich jetzt, da sind wir jetzt absolut bei zweihundertachtundsechzigtausend Fällen rund.
Im Moment kommen tausendfünfhundert am Tag dazu ansteigend und es sterben etwa vier Menschen pro Tag in äh Deutschland, wobei die Tendenz
langsam jetzt steigend ist, also die ist jetzt.
Auf einunddreißig in den letzten sieben Tagen gestiegen in den sieben Tagen davor waren's noch einundzwanzig, also auch da bewegt sich langsam äh was
und äh ja überhaupt wenn wir jetzt zu Deutschland kommen oder hast du noch irgendwas zu international.
Ja, Plätze haben wir dieses europäische Bild äh so ein bisschen mal
versuchen zu zeichnen. Ich meine, da könnte man jetzt noch äh verschiedene Länder nennen. Ich weiß auch, dass es in Tschechien jetzt auch äh mal ein bisschen wilder geworden ist, weil Tschechien hatten wir ja zwischendurch auch schon mal gesprochen, da hat so auch die Einschätzung, dass die damit ja generell schon irgendwie ganz gut,
äh klarkommen würden. Das war zumindest deine Einschätzung. Ich glaube, es hat sich da jetzt auch etwas äh latent dramatisiert. Ähm.
Dann gibt's natürlich auch immer wieder so diesen Blick nach Schweden, ne,
die Zahlen glaube ich gerade nicht so explodieren, aber die halt einfach über den gesamten Zeitraum,
sehr viele Tote hatten, äh immer noch, glaube ich, das fünffache im Schnitt ähm zu Deutschland, also fünffache
wieder relativ zur Bevölkerungszahl, die fünffache Zahl. Ähm! Ja, und das glaube ich so.
Je nach, je nach je nachdem wie sehr man das jetzt sozusagen an diesen Zahlen festmachen möchte, ist ja auch nochmal so eine Debatte
für sich 'ne schwierige Debatte, aber sie wird ja leider auch geführt, dass ja worauf legt man's an, ne? Also
nimmt man irgendwie
die das Überleben der gesamten Gesellschaft irgendwie in den Fokus und zieht dabei vielleicht auch noch ein paar andere Aspekte mit rein, wirtschaftlich und so weiter, da werden wir nochmal drüber sprechen
oder sind Tote an sich schon der Maßstab für alles, danach
gemessen, hat Schweden jetzt nicht sehr viel besser abgeschnitten.
Ja, da kommen wir später noch.
Ne? Genau.
Drauf, wobei die aktuelle Entwicklung in Schweden jetzt erstmal nicht so viel
Anlass äh äh zur äh Sorge gibt im Vergleich mit anderen Ländern, ja, aber Tschechien in der Tat. Ich meine, Tschechien hat ja eigentlich die
erste Welle so fast äh ja da war irgendwie kaum was, da waren irgendwie im im Höhepunkt irgendwie dreihundert Fälle äh äh pro Tag bei der ersten Welle bei
ja äh.
Irgendwie auch um die zehn Millionen Einwohnern ungefähr, also vergleichbar
mit mit Belgien und Belgien hatte mehr Tote am Tag als Tschechien infiziert. Also das war irgendwie Faktor hundert
aber aktuell sind da die Zahlen jetzt wirklich in die Höhe äh geschossen, also vielleicht sagen, Tschechien hat jetzt
gerade so was wie die erste Welle.
Erste richtige Welle mit äh im Moment ja, dem Vierfachen, also so um die.
Zweitausend neue Infektionen pro Tag und das ist das ist natürlich eher unschön.
Überhaupt verteilte sich einfach über Europa extrem, ungleichmäßig,
gesehen von diesen Spätausreißern, trifft's halt unter unter anderem die Länder stark, die ist vorher schon mal stark betroffen hat, Spanien Frankreich, nicht aber Italien,
Also es es lässt sich irgendwie so richtig kein,
richtiges Bild zeichnen, ja, wo man sagen könnte, ja, weil das das so und so am Anfang äh gelaufen ist oder nicht gelaufen ist, deswegen ist es jetzt so, sondern es scheint mir doch eher eine grundsätzliche Fähigkeiten der Fähigkeit der Gesellschaft zu sein, die darüber entscheidet
wie man einfach mit dem Fakt, dass der Virus in der Welt ist äh umgeht.
Ja, es scheint es scheint irgendwie kein äh klares Muster zu geben. Das einzige äh was man halt.
Rausziehen kann ist sein einzige.
Was übereinstimmt ist, dass das Verhältnis von gemeldeten Neuinfektionen zu gemeldeten Todesfällen äh am Anfang einen radikal anderes.
Ähm das kann halt auch daran liegen, dass bei der ersten Welle, weil noch nicht so viel getestet äh wurde, einfach ganz viele Fälle durchgerutscht.
Dass wir halt bei der ersten Welle äh einfach massive Dunkelziffern hatten, die wir jetzt nicht mehr haben. Das äh spielt sicherlich auch da rein.
Plus jetzt im Fall von Deutschland, das sagt zumindest auch.
RKI ähm und das trifft auch für andere Länder. Ich glaube für die Schweiz trifft es auch zu und für Österreich, dass halt jetzt vor allem junge Leute.
Gerade hauptsächlich erkrank.
Und äh dass dann dass das halt auch dazu führt, dass viel weniger Leute sterben,
allerdings äh so, was man aus manchen anderen Ländern äh äh sieht oder gerade ja wohl in in der Schweiz auch dann sehen kann und dass.
Sagen auch erstes ja bei den in den jüngeren Bevölkerungsschichten bei gerade bei den zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen war es wohl in der Schweiz sehr hoch.
Ähm.
Dass das anschließend äh dann äh doch sich in die wieder in die älteren äh.
Bevölkerungsgruppen überträgt und dann anschließend eben auch wieder die Sterblichkeit äh dann wieder wieder anziehen.
Es wäre sehr hilfreich, wenn man bei dieser Sterblichkeit jetzt mal wirklich auch zu dieser Alters äh Kohorten ähm herauslesen äh könnte, ne.
Ja ich war ja schon irgendwie heute drauf und dran, weil ich eben habe ich ja die Daten und ich müsste wahrscheinlich irgendwie nur sind zwei, drei Stunden wahrscheinlich Arbeit äh um
die Tabellen da rauszuziehen für die einzelnen jetzt für Deutschland.
Bist du auf Twitter noch nicht genug gescheucht worden.
Ja, das wäre in der Tat äh ganz interessant, weil die Zahlen, wie du sagst, liegen ja in dem Sinne äh vor und dann könnte man eben dieser
diese Todeszahl quasi ja mal so in unterschiedliche
Bereiche aufteilen, also eine kleine Analyse quasi machen, um zu sehen, okay, welche Altersstufen
in welchen Altersstufen nehmen denn jetzt gerade äh die Todesfälle zu ist, sagen wir mal, der Bereich der älteren konstant im Wesentlichen oder also relativ zu den Infektionen konstant,
oder was passiert jetzt hier eigentlich gerade? Das finde ich wirklich mal ganz spannend und glaube, um,
die Situation auch irgendwie mal einschätzen zu werden, weil es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere Faktoren, die mit äh äh reinkommen. Wir haben jetzt natürlich.
Mehr Erfahrung im Klinikbetrieb, dass die Fälle.
Ja, man weiß jetzt einfach oder sollte zumindest äh davon geht's mir davon aus, ja, dass jetzt
mehr und mehr Informationen darüber vorliegen, was man nicht macht. Also das sozusagen Behandlungen, die eine vollkommen falsche Richtung gehen unterlassen werden. Es gibt ja nun auch schon ein oder zwei Medikamente, die insbesondere bei den harten Fällen
helfen, ja? Dass wenn die früh angewendet werden, hab diese Substanz da, die in UK da ähm rausgefunden wurde, ob ich jetzt gerade nicht p
parat, aber das sind alles so kleine Mittelchen, wo man gemerkt hat, in einer bestimmten Phase der Erkrankung können damit irgendwie bestimmte äh Chancen erhöht werden, um eben einen Tod zu vermeiden und das natürlich alles Faktoren, die jetzt hier mit
äh reinkommen. Insgesamt nimmt natürlich dadurch so ein bisschen der Dramatisierungsfaktor ab.
Weil ja hohe Infektionszahlen zahlen gehen hochzahlen geht runter, das rauscht jetzt äh so ein bisschen als Hintergrundinformation in den Nachrichten,
durch und wenn man's halt nicht merkt im Sinne von.
Starke äh Infektionszahlen äh im eigenen Umfeld oder im schlimmsten Fall eben auch noch äh gestorbene Menschen. Tja, dann alarmiert
man sich natürlich als Gesellschaft auch nicht mehr so und ich denke, dass eben grade diese Nachlassen der dieser inneren Alarmierung.
Gepaart mit einem extremen,
sozialen Nachholbedürfnis dazu führt, dass eben natürlich jetzt die mobilen Teile der Gesellschaft, also zwanzig,
dreißigjährigen, die halt sehr viel mehr im Leben stehen und sehr viel höheren Kontaktbedarf haben. Das jetzt alles trotzdem haben wollen und dann eben trotzdem den Virus durch die Gegend tragen.
Ja, dann lass uns doch mal nach äh Deutschland gucken, was da jetzt Phase ist. Also du hast ja gerade schon gesagt, ähm tausendfünfhundert pro Tag haben wir derzeit im Mittel
aber nur vier Tote pro Tag aber die Zahlen gehen hoch.
Jacken und zwar ich meine wir hatten ja beim letzten Mal hatten wir so die dritte Welle äh war ja dann.
Auf dem Höhepunkt beziehungsweise sah so aus, als wenn sie ihren Höhepunkt überschritten hätte. Das hat aber nur eine Woche angehalten und seit einer Woche,
die Zahlen wieder angezogen und wir haben
jetzt äh ja einen sozusagen einen neuen Rekord mit den tausendfünfhundert pro Tag
an Neuinfektion also hoch war's seit Mitte April nicht mehr und
sagen, die
dritte Welle, also man kann jetzt diskutieren, es ist jetzt irgendwie eine vierte Welle, äh also nimmt man die Delle mit rein oder hatte die dritte Welle jetzt eine Delle. Das kann man so oder so äh hal
also aber ich würde sagen, es ist immer noch jetzt definitiv die dritte äh Welle, weil es nicht so weit runtergegangen ist, äh wie.
Ähm zwischen der ersten und zweiten und der zweiten und dritten äh Welle waren wir.
Sagen ungefähr gleichweit unten äh mit den Zahlen der Neuinfektion, also unter hundert äh am Tag äh waren wir ja.
Schon und äh ja das Ganze zeigt sich halt auch äh wieder in allen Bundesländern.
Überall sind die Zahlen gestiegen.
So ähm das war zwischenzeitlich ja auch anders. Da hatten wir halt immer nur einen Teil oder.
Über die Hälfte hatte dann wieder fallende Zahlen zwischenzeitlich, aber jetzt äh sagen Ziehzeit überall an.
Und ja, Bayern vorne äh so und äh Hamburg und Berlin,
so, sind gerade bei meiner Risikobewertung vorne und NRW und Baden-Württemberg sehen auch nicht so gut aus. Alle anderen Länder sind halt unterm äh Bundesdurchschnitt,
und das ist auch durchaus ein realer Anstieg, weil guckt mal auf die Testzahlen sind die Tests war jetzt auf ein neues Allzeithoch angestiegene letz
Woche beziehungsweise ja in der KW sieben dreißig gab's eins Komma eins zwei Millionen Tests.
Und dabei ist also wir sind ungefähr fünfzigtausend mehr gewesen als in der Woche davor, aber die positiven Quote ist mit angestiegen von null Komma sieben vier auf null Komma acht sechs Prozent, das heißt ähm.
Also ist ein echter Anstieg und äh ja wir haben halt über zehntausend neue Infektionen in den letzten sieben Tagen.
Gehabt so und,
Gut warum, also und aber die Zahl der Toten, wie gesagt, weiterhin äh niedrig, leicht ansteigend und das Thema junge Leute haben ja gerade schon,
schon besprochen und schaut mal jetzt noch ein bisschen tiefer in die Landkreise rein. Es,
Bayern nach wie vor am häufigsten vertreten hätten. Die hatten letzte Woche zwischenzeitlich die die,
dreißig irgendwie fast alleine besitzt äh äh jetzt äh immerhin noch sechzehn von dreißig Kreisen
und Bedenklich dabei ist, dass halt fünf Kreise nämlich Kulmbach, Garmisch,
Kirchen, Würzburg, München und Kaufbeuren, die fünfzig Fälle pro hunderttausend Institanz überschreiten, bei denen eigentlich,
diese Kreise ja als Risikogebiete gelten und eigentlich Maßnahmen getroffen werden müssten. Ähm,
in München ist es so, äh dass.
Offiziell die Zahl noch unter fünfzig Fällen pro hunderttausend liegen bei mir aber schon deut.
Rüber, was wieder an den berühmten sieben Tage äh,
Loch äh liegt, sage ich mal, weil eben nach wie vor für die offizielle Institzberechnung fällt alles weg, was,
länger als sieben Tage braucht von.
Mensch meldet sich beim Gesundheitsamt bis der Fall wird ans RKI gemeldet oder wird elektronisch erfasst und wenn das länger als sieben Tage,
äh dauert, dann werden fallen diese Fälle komplett unter den Tisch und München hat irgendwie sechs Komma drei Tage durchschnittliche
sagen, Meldeverzögerung,
was halt heißt, dass so ein Teil wahrscheinlich zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Prozent oder so größenordnungsmäßig der Fälle niemals in die sieben Tagesinstitenz eingehen, weil's einfach zu lange äh dauer,
äh bis sie gemeldet werden. So und äh ja, so mogelt.
Ja, so äh ciao.
So mogelt sich München grade äh äh gerade äh durch, obwohl eigentlich äh ja.
Was halt auch ein bisschen ärgerlich ist, weil ich nächste Woche nach München.
Oha. Oha.
Begeistert mich jetzt gar nicht, ja?
Urlaub im Risiko Risikogebiet.
Ja, es ist eher ein ein Gerichtstermin, den ich wahrnehmen mus.
Äh dort äh so also auch nix, was man jetzt, wo man jetzt sagen kann, ach nee, das schieben wir mal oder so. Ähm.
Ja äh ansonsten auch noch äh erwähnenswert vielleicht ein paar größere Ausbrüche in Cloppenburg im Weimarer Land und in Mühlheim, wo ich jetzt nicht hinterher recherchiert habe, was es jetzt genau war, aber
in der Regel wenn man dann die Landkreise plus Corona eingibt kommt dann sehr schnell bei Google.
Was denn dort eigentlich passiert.
Ja, vielleicht jetzt noch äh bei den Zahlen noch ein Blick.
Unserer Heimatstadt Berlin die zu.
Bisschen zwar grundsätzlich auch im Bundestrend liegt, aber dann doch Kurven etwas anders äh laufen, also wichtiger Unterschied.
War, dass wir Mitte Juni in Berlin so ein kleine zweite Welle hatten, die.
Deutlich höher und ausgeprägter war, als das, was im Bund passiert ist und.
Deswegen sind wir jetzt bei der dritten Welle hat es relativ lange gedauert äh bis wir diese zweite die Gipfel der zweiten Welle eingeholt haben, das ist aber jetzt passiert
und äh ja, wir sind also jetzt auch in in Berlin.
Wieder auf dem Level von Mitte April äh angekommen bei.
Beim sieben Tagesschnitt an Neuinfektion
allerdings auch hier in den letzten zwei Wochen ist in Berlin genau eine Person an Kowit gestorben und aus den Daten war nur ersichtlich, dass sie weiblich war über achtzig Jahre und aus Reinickendorf kam.
Also äh kann man sagen und davor in den in den.
Drei Wochen davor waren's zwei Fälle so, also da heißt es sterben äh auch in Berlin.
Eher wenig äh Menschen kaum bis niemand und auch ähm so die,
die allerletzten Zahlen nicht, aber es lagen so größenordnungsmäßig, zehn Leute mit,
auf der Intensivstation und ein Großteil davon, aber schon seit April. So, also da sind ein paar ein Großteil davon sind,
Langzeitpatienten, ne.
Ja, ein paar Leute erwischen es ja auch wirklich knallerhart und die haben laufenden Meter äh Rückfälle, ja.
Ja.
Und verteilen tut sich's halt vor allem also ähm wenn man jetzt in die Bezirke noch reinguckt, Friedrichshain Kreuzberg Mitte und Neukölln vorne, Tempelhof Schöneberg,
auch ein bisschen jetzt angezogen und alles alle mit sieben Tage Institut von über zwanzig pro hunderttausend,
bis jetzt noch nicht direkt.
Risikogebiet, aber ist so schon langsam an dem Level, wo es wo es für die Gesundheitsämter hart wird. Aber.
Zentrum sozusagen.
Ja, also es ist wird langsam wieder stressig äh so für die Ämter, äh weil's da auch die schon mal eine Überforderungssituation hatten vor ein paar Wochen, wo einfach
Meldungen liegen geblieben sind in größerem Umfang und Leute nicht gewarnt werden
konnten also Kontakte nicht gewarnt werden konnten, weil niemand da war, um die zu warnen. So, aber.
Auf Mallorca beispielsweise haben wir nicht zwanzig pro hunderttausend, sondern im Moment hundertfünfzig pro hunderttausend, also da gibt's gerade,
Äh ja, richtig ab äh und auch in einigen anderen Gegenden in in Spanien, wo einfach auch wieder massiv runtergefahren.
Wird gerade das gesellschaftliche Leben mit auch ausgangsbeschränkungen und so zweiundzwanzig Uhr muss alles dicht machen und so und äh ja,
alles. Also von daher sind Deutschland und in Berlin jetzt noch nicht so dramatisch, aber es geht natürlich definitiv in die falsche Richtung und.
Wir hatten ja bei der in der letzten Sendung war das die Perkulationstheorie.
Wo vielleicht ja zur Erläuterung magst du.
Ja, das war sozusagen dieses Bild, Perkulation, also diese durch äh Sickerung, äh das kurz gesagt,
In dem Moment, wo eine Gesellschaft schon,
hohe Infektionszahlen erlitten hat, eine hohe Verbreitung gefunden hat, dass es danach umso einfacher ist
dort auch wieder neue Wellen anzustoßen
weil einfach schon so viel latente Infektionen mehr oder weniger unbemerkt äh vorhanden sind. Das in dem Moment, wo so ein gewisser Überdruck
noch mit eingetragen wird durch durch Superspredder oder äh neue Infektionen, die von außen herein getragen werden
Das ist dann eben schnell überschlägt, dass dass es dann eben sehr viel leichter sein kann, dass es eben sich so ausbreitet. Und,
Frankreich scheinen so ein bisschen dafür zu sprechen, aber Italien wiederum.
Genau. Es gibt auch, ich habe seitdem, seit ich davon erfahren habe, habe ich auch wieder genug Gegenbeispiele gefunden, die eigentlich eher dagegen sprechen. Aber äh was,
definitiv der der Fall ist. Es gib.
Definitiv ein Punkt, äh wenn die Zahl der täglichen Infektionen den überschreitet, dann kommen einfach die Gesundheitsämter nicht mehr mit und,
die Gesundheitsämter und das Isolieren von infizierten Personen ist halt.
Definitiv ein wichtiger Faktor, der einfach dieses berühmte R den Reproduktionsfaktor nach unten zieht. So äh oder eindämmt auf jeden Fall so.
Irgendeinem.
Reinzugrätschen, also Platz zwei auf deiner Tabelle ist ja Garmisch-Partenkirchen, ich weiß nicht, ob du den Fall mitbekommen hast, da gab's ja,
von dieser Amerikanerin, die äh dort ähm unter Quarantäne gestellt worden ist vom
Gesundheitsamt sich dann aber nicht dran gehalten hat, sondern irgendwie durch alle äh Bars und Partybezirke der Stadt äh durchgezogen ist und dabei irgendwie einen Shitloat an Leuten äh infiziert hat und die jetzt auch mit höheren Bußgeldern zu rechnen hat, weil
Na ja, ne? Also ich meine, du kannst sozusagen auch wenn die Leute nicht mitspielen, äh hast natürlich auch schlechte Karten.
Genau, in dem Fall sieht man halt, dass eine Person, die dann halt super spreader ist, so ja hunderte bis tausende äh infizieren kann und äh einen kompletten,
'n kompletten Landkreis ja lahmliegen kann, ne? Aber also mein Punkt ist äh an.
An irgendeinem äh Punkt.
So äh ja bricht halt äh dieser dieser Schutz weg, weil einfach ja, sowohl die Gesundheitsämter, wie auch das Testwesen und so überfordert ist und.
Wenn dann sagen noch dieser Damm wegbricht und sowieso schon Druck da ist, das ist dann glaube ich auch der Moment äh wo es dann äh nach oben schießt, weil eben ja äh an dem sozusagen an dem R, äh lass,
irgendwie durch die Gesundheitsämter, die Aktivitäten des R um null Komma eins bis null Komma zwei reduzieren und wir sind jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwo zwischen eins und eins Komma eins in Berlin, wie auch im,
im Bund und wenn dann plötzlich nochmal null Komma eins oder null Komma zwei auf den R drauf kommen
von dem ausgehend dann sowieso schon von sag mal tausend Fällen am,
am Tag äh oder sagen wir mal hundert Fällen äh am Tag, dann kann's natürlich richtig explodieren. Also es wäre eher meine These, es ist eher vielleicht,
Dammbruchtheorie äh und weniger äh Perkulation, wo.
Sind wir jetzt noch bei Berlin oder ähm bist du jetzt schon wieder auf so eine Meterebene äh.
Könnten. Also wir sind Berlin im Prinzip bin ich, bin ich jetzt auch eigentlich.
So durch äh mit ähm sagt äh ja bisschen schlechter als im Bund. Die Zahlen aber jetzt auch nicht dramatisch schlechter.
Aber äh ja mein Anzeichen dafür, dass es halt, dass die Zahlen allmählich zu hoch sind, ist auch äh zunehmende Proben, Rückstau, der,
begonnen hat, als man angefangen hat, die Reiserückkehrer zu testen.
Jetzt generell in Deutschland oder in Berlin.
Ja, in Deutschland, also es ist nur in Deutschland. Genau. Und äh ja, das bedeutet halt.
Das es manche Leute äh,
Ihre Testergebnisse verzögert Tage äh später erhalten, als es eigentlich äh sein
sollte und ja derjenige ist es auch noch nicht gelungen jetzt abzubauen, den den Rückstau gerade.
Wo hast du denn diese Zahl her eigentlich? Wieso, wo hast du diese Zahl her, mit diesem Probenrückstau.
Das ist auch äh vom RKI der äh das RKI veröffentlicht ja immer noch seine Tagesberichte und ich gucke da jeden jede Woche in den Mittwochsbericht rein, weil dort auch die Testzahlen veröffentlicht,
und in dem,
Zusammenhang äh werden auch die Kapazitäten und der Rückstau in den Laboren äh mit abgefragt. Ist zwar jetzt nicht vollständig. So.
Aber äh ja denke auf jeden Fall schon repräsentativ.
Ist aber ganz schön viel, also hier für die letzte Woche, also das mal so locker paar und dreißigtausend.
Ja, gut bei, ich sage mal, von, ja, von.
Sag mal 'ne Million beziehungsweise ja ungefähr, weiß nicht hundertachtzigtausend am Tag heißt das das so ungefähr ja ähm das.
Sind das so einen Fünftel ungefähr zwanzig Prozent äh ungefähr liegen bleiben.
Gerade, also nicht das die ja zwanzig Prozent liegen lassen müssen für die nächsten oder übernächsten Tag oder wie lange auch immer.
Das dauert.
Und ja Grund ist auch so ein Viertel der Labore meldet irgendwie Probleme bei der Beschaffung von äh Testchemikalien und Testkids und so.
Aber noch sind wohl die Kapazitäten grundsätzlich da, also wir haben eigentlich hätten noch zweihunderttausend Tests mehr gemacht werden können, aber.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch regional unterschiedlich verteilt wieder und.
Aber man sieht, also es ist sagen wir so, dass das System äh ist unter Stress wieder. So, das kann man, kann man sagen.
Ja. Äh da kann man vielleicht zusammengefasst jetzt sagen ähm.
Zahlen gehen definitiv in die falsche Richtung so. Ähm, es sollte nicht so sein, ähm.
Vor allem gut mit den Jüngeren, dass die sich gerade infizieren, das ist, hält jetzt die Auswirkungen oder die Belastung des Gesundheitssystems relativ gering, aber äh sag,
Befürchtung ist da, dass das nicht so bleibt, sondern dass das eben auch die älteren jetzt demnächst wieder erwischt. Und da gibt's wohl äh Beispiele aus anderen.
Ändern, wo das genauso gekommen ist. Und wir hatten, glaube ich, auch mal.
Bereits eine so eine Phase, wo sich das, wo sich das Ganze verlagert hatte. Also von daher kann man nur a,
vor allem an die Jüngeren appellieren, besser aufzupassen, gerade weil in der Altersgruppe scheinen jetzt gerade die meisten Infektionen stattzufinden und außerdem Risikopersonen sollten sich gerade äh,
ja in Anwesenheit junger Menschen besonders gut schützen, weil diese eben oft auch symptomlos und trotzdem ansteckend sind und ja, das ist natürlich eine eine besonders gefährliche.
Situation. Ja, so viel, ich sage mal zu den aktuellen.
Zahlen äh in Deutschland und Berlin und der Welt von meiner Seite.
Wo wir gerade über äh testen ähm reden. Ich äh hatte ja letzte Woche angekündigt, äh auf Reisen zu gehen und mich dann auch selber mal deswegen testen zu lassen.
Und hatte äh schon
großspürig äh angekündigt, äh äh dass sich das so jeder nur erdenklichen Gelegenheit tun will. Die erste Gelegenheit ist mir dann gleich äh entronnen aus äh Zeitgründen äh und auch noch ein bisschen,
mit der Überlegung
Das ist für meine Reise nicht so richtig viel Sinn macht, da äh hätte ich dann hier quasi noch bevor ich losgefahren bin
bei einem Hausarzt, Hausärztin, äh, den Test machen können an einem Freitag, aber eben auch erst
am Montag mein mein Testergebnis bekommen
dann ja ohnehin schon mal zwei Tage alt ist und an dem Wochenende war das jetzt auch noch nicht so das dramatische Problem für mich. Ich wollte es eigentlich eher für die nächste Woche haben. Deswegen nach äh ein wenig Recherche. Ich war dann in Düsseldorf.
Da habe ich dann nämlich herausgefunden, dass in Düsseldorf direkt am Hauptbahnhof so eine wie das wie das so schön hieß. Corona Walkin äh Option besteht,
Klingt ja eigentlich nicht so schön, Corona Walkin, wenn.
Corona einfach äh herein marschiert, aber es meint natürlich ein Test, wo man einfach auftauchen kann und ohne irgendwelche Angabe von Gründen einen Test bekommt,
Also du kannst natürlich Gründe nennen, das hängt dann das entscheidet dann darüber, wer dafür bezahlt. In dem Fall war das bei mir klar, da würde ich dann halt äh selber bezahlen, weil ich halt Interviews machen wollte und,
ist mir zwar nicht als Bedingung genannt worden.
Aber ich dachte mir so, jetzt bin ich hier der Intruder. Jetzt will ich mir zumindest sicher sein, dass ich jetzt hier nicht irgendwas reintrage.
Und davon abgesehen wollte ich halt einfach mal diesen Prozess äh durchhaben. Na ja, das war dann am Montag früh.
Dieser Container, der da steht ähm unweit des Hauptbahnhofs hätte schon um sieben Uhr geöffnet gehabt, da hätte ich vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen früher aufstehen sollen, so kam ich hin und da war da schon relativ.
Lange, na ja, lange Schlange, ne, war eine Schlange,
dass es da halt irgendwie eine halbe Stunde warten musste, bis ich rankam, ähm.
Pro Person, nachdem die so.
Einmal ein Container rein und wieder rauskam, meine Beobachtung war so ungefähr fünf Minuten, hab's bei mir jetzt selber nicht so getestet, aber das hing dann eben teilweise
immer von den Fällen ab, also bei mir ging's relativ zügig, aber ich hatte so den Eindruck, da war dann eben auch Reisende aus anderen Ländern und so weiter und dann musste halt erstmal äh ganz viele Sachen klären
Na ja, wie auch immer, man kommt da äh reinmarschiert, sagt halt hier, ich bin hm
und dann kriegt man so ein kleines Kärtchen mit einem äh Barcode drauf, natürlich kein Cona Warnapp, kompatibles äh Kärtchen.
Immerhin war das so ein Unternehmen, was halt selber so eine App draußen hat.
Kein kein kein App-Preis gewinnen würde, ja? Das ist so im Wesentlichen so eine kleine äh Mini-App, die äh in der Lage ist, diesen QR-Code zu lesen und damit irgendein Reques auf irgendeinem Webserver macht und dann.
Sagt na ja ich kann dir Bescheid sagen hier Notification ähm beziehungsweise.
Lege das Ergebnis schon vor, würde es mir dann auch gleich anzeigen
Ja, dann äh hatte ich noch die Wahl selber mir den die Probe entnehmen zu lassen, also die mir selber zu entnehmen oder sie mir entnehmen zu lassen, da habe ich dann gesagt, nee, ich vertraue hier mal ganz auf äh die Profis, äh mein erster Test, ich wollte ja
sozusagen erstmal spüren, was was da sozusagen in meinem Körper äh passieren soll, wie sich das anfühlen soll, um's auch selber im Zweifelsfall äh machen zu können.
Ja gut das war dann nicht weiter schlimm, Ritchel Ritchel hinten bisschen am Rachen, dann kommt das halt da in so eine kleine.
Plastikkartusche und dann ja ist man eigentlich auch schon wieder raus aus dem Haus. Mir wurde dann gesagt, na ja, weil gerade so viel los ist, könnte es.
Was war das Versprechen? Äh äh sechsunddreißig Stunden dauern. Das war so ihre Aussage.
Aber tatsächlich hatte ich zwölf Stunden später schon das Ergebnis. Was dann negativ war.
Und ja, damit äh das passte mir dann natürlich ganz wunderbar in den Kram, weil ich halt,
bei Leuten auftauchen konnte und nicht nur so sinnlose Formulare ausgefüllt habe mit äh ich habe mich nicht in einem Risikogebiet gefunden, sondern äh,
hätte halt auch noch, hat keiner drauf bestanden, aber ich hätte halt auch noch sagen können oder hab's dann natürlich meinen Gesprächspartnern gesagt, so ja hier, also.
Von mir ist nicht viel zu befürchten, ich bin hier nachgewiesenermaßen äh negativ und wenn ich mittlerweile schon wieder äh mich infiziert habe, dann,
ist unser Interview schon lange vorbei, bevor es äh schlimm wird. Ja, war insofern für mich natürlich eine ganz positive äh.
Erfahrung, weil ich nicht viel Zeit reingesteckt habe. Letzten Endes habe ich da so eine Stunde mit äh mit verbracht mit der ganzen Wartereihe. Ja und am Ende habe ich sogar digital direkt äh auf mein Telefon ein Ergebnis bekommen,
Die mich annehme, das stimmte und alles gut.
Es hätte noch eine zweite Möglichkeit bestanden, dass am am Flughafen zu machen, Flughafen Frankfurt, was nicht so hundertprozentig auf meinem Weg lag, deswegen habe ich den Umweg dann nicht genommen.
Und ja und weitere Gelegenheiten musste ich dann nicht äh haben. Also grundsätzlich ist das so ein Prozess, den ich äh wiederholen würde. Ach ja und Preis fünfundsiebzig Euro.
Was ungefähr so die Hälfte, ja ungefähr die Hälfte, also das scheint mir so ein bisschen gerade so der der Endkundenpreis zu sein. Wenn du eben direkt in so einem Probenzentrum aufläufst von dem Labor, was das auch selber durchführt,
Während wenn das eben über Ärzte läuft, dann quasi dann nochmal so ein.
Extra Aufschlag für die Dienstleistung der Probenentnahme kommt, die so nach äh Ärztetarifen berechnet wird und dann ist halt ein bisschen teurer.
Nachvollziehbar. Insofern, ne? Empfehlung. Ja, wenn man einen günstigen Test haben will, dann eher wahrscheinlich beim so einem Testzentrum, als bei einem Arzt.
Wenn man sowas in der Nähe hat, ne? Also da müsste man äh dann mal schauen. Gut, dann hatten wir so ein bisschen äh schon angesprochen.
Diese Abwägung zwischen wie schlimm sind denn jetzt die Maßnahmen? Versus wie schlimm sind denn die Auswirkungen der Maßnahmen? Das ist ja so eine Debatte, die wir eigentlich auch schon.
Von Anfang an hatten und wir wollten auch mal so einen Blick werfen auf ja das, was ich vielleicht an Zahlen ganz gut ablest, nämlich wirtschaftliche Entwicklung.
Wie sehr haben einzelne Länder.
Sich einerseits geschützt und andererseits wie viel wirtschaftlichen Schaden haben sie durch die ganze Situation gehabt? Was ja nicht unbedingt immer bedeuten muss, dass sie unmittelbaren wirtschaftlichen Schaden durch die eigenen Maßnahmen im eigenen Land hatten.
Können einen auch der wirtschaftliche Schaden anderer Länder und Veränderungen in der Gesellschaft anderer Länder mit denen man viel zu tun hat oder wo die eigene Wirtschaft
äh eben stark von abhängt, kannst du natürlich auch mit zu tun haben. Klar, soweit haben wir das jetzt nicht aufgedröselt, aber was hast du für Zahlen gefunden.
Ja also als ich mich auf die Suche gemacht hab nach irgendwie,
Zahlen, wie sich denn die Wirtschaft entwickelt hat, bin ich eigentlich genau auf schon eine brauchbare Auswertung bei Hour World in Deta,
gestoßen, die ja ohnehin ganz viele verschiedene Daten aggregieren und dann freundlicherweise sogar einen äh eine Grafik gemacht haben, wo sie
auf der einen Seite den Rückgang,
Bruttoinlandsprodukt im zweiten Quartal, also von äh sagen wir mal April äh April, Mai, Juni.
So ähm auf der einen Achse.
Und auf der anderen äh Achse ähm die äh Zahl der Menschen, die,
bis Ende August äh dort an Kovit gestorben sind relativ zur Bevölkerung. Äh.
Des Landes. Sprich ja, auf der einen Seite haben wir sagen,
Größe des wirtschaftlichen Einbruchs und auf der anderen Achse eben ja äh wie viele Menschen hat es erwischt äh in dem Land, also tödlich.
Sowas äh auf jeden Fall verlässlicher ist als jetzt irgendwelche infizierten Zahlen, die natürlich,
mal durch, also deutlich stärker verzerrt äh sind als jetzt die Zahl der Leute, die sterben und ja.
Das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Ähm wenn man da nämlich draufschaut, kann man schon sehen, dass.
Von Ausnahmen abgesehen, aber grundsätzlich, dass sagen die Länder, die am,
schlechtesten dastehen, also wie UK und Spanien, äh wo halt äh über
sechshundert Menschen pro Million Einwohner gestorben sind an Kowit, dass die auch den stärksten wirtschaftlichen
Einbruch hatten, nämlich über zwanzig Prozent
weniger Bruttoinlandsprodukt, also irgendwie zwar Spanien, zweiundzwanzig Komma eins und UK einundzwanzig Komma sieben.
Das sind sozusagen,
die zwei Länder, wo man sagen kann, dass dies insgesamt am schlechtesten äh äh bewältigt haben, während am anderen Ende des Spektrums äh ja Taiwan,
so äh hatte.
Kaum wirtschaftlichen Einbruch null Komma sechs Prozent, also da war fast nix und hatte auch,
nur null Komma drei. Ja, also UK sechshundert, Taiwan null Komma drei,
Tote pro Millionen Einwohner.
Und ähnlich auch also Süd-Südkorea äh drei Prozent Rückgang und sechs Komma drei,
pro Million, also ein also da gibt es sagen so einen generellen Trend, wobei es da auch ein paar Ausreißer gibt.
Belgien,
einfach noch schlimmer äh bei den Toten, nämlich irgendwie achthundertdreiundfünfzig pro Million, hat aber nur.
In Anführungszeichen vierzehn Komma fünf Prozent eingebüßt, also fahrt wirtschaftlich das besser durchgehalten als jetzt ja UK oder Spanien, ne? Ähm.
Und ähm ja desweiteren USA und Schweden, die auch beide
in der Gegend von UK und Spanien liegen, was die Toten angeht
haben sich aber wirtschaftlich beide besser behauptet USA minus neun Komma fünf und Schweden minus acht Komma drei
im Vergleich dazu Deutschland minus elf Komma sieben, also.
Sind sogar im zweiten Quartal bis geringfügig besser äh gelaufen, wobei man natürlich abwarten muss ähm,
in den beiden Ländern ist es teilweise erst ja etwas später hochgekocht äh oder die Maßnahmen erst später gegriffen. Insofern wird wahrscheinlich interessanter auch wie es im zwei,
äh wie es im dritten und vierten Quartal und im nächsten Jahr aussieht. Auf jeden Fall ist diese
Grafik oder diese Art das darzustellen auf jeden Fall sagen recht interessant,
und insbesondere, weil das auch auf Twitter an mich herangetragen wurde, die Frage, ja Schweden, weil da gibt es dann so Urin ja, guckt nach Schweden, die haben eigentlich alles offen gelassen und da ist jetzt auch nicht schlimmer
als anderswo, aber das stimmt so,
nicht, weil äh vergleicht man jetzt insbesondere Schweden mit.
Ja Norwegen und Finnland und Litauen beispielsweise dann.
Steht es vergleichsweise wirklich schlecht dar. Und ja ähm weil,
beide Länder hatten sowohl wirtschaftlich und vor allem aber auch beim Bevölkerungsschutz äh in
äh fallen sie in eine andere Dimension, also Finnland hatte gerade mal fünf, fünf Prozent
äh Einbuße Norwegen auch, also fünf Komma zwei, fünf Komma drei Litauen,
sogar nur drei Komma sieben Prozent und beide äh waren aber.
Mit um die ja fünf zwischen dreißig und.
Sechzig Toten pro Millionen Einwohner haben äh ja einfach zehn Mal weniger,
Tote zu verzeichnen oder nur ein Zehntel der Toten zu verzeichnen pro Bevölkerung. Insofern,
waren definitiv sagen äh ja Schweden hat's verkackt äh so. Ja also es hat nicht funktioniert. Äh wobei, wie gesagt, wirtschaftlich es nicht nicht ganz so schlimm.
Äh äh war wie in anderen äh Ländern und auch in den in den USA.
Wobei man eigentlich jetzt genauer jetzt gucken müsste, was sind denn eigentlich die Branchen, äh wo das Bruttoinlandsprodukt erwirtschaftet wird und
wie wird es erwirtschaftet, weil natürlich, wenn nur wie die USA auch eine starke Digitalindustrie
äh hast jetzt die profitiert, dann eher sogar von Corona, also.
Man will nicht wissen, wie viel jetzt Zoom oder Microsoft äh oder äh auch,
Orecal jetzt zusätzlich an Einnahmen hatten, weil die ganzen Videokonferenzsysteme aufgerüstet oder eingeführt äh äh werden.
Ja auch Apple hat irgendwie deutlich mehr Laptops, IPads verkauft und so, mehr als ihr erwartet haben.
Plus, wenn die Leute genau, das ist in die Leute dann zu Hause sitzen, äh zu Hause arbeiten, äh überlegen sich halt auch, dass sie irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen besser äh sich sich äh ja ausstatten.
Und den USA hilft's natürlich auch immer noch so ein bisschen auch die Leitwirtschaft zu sein. Also äh den geht's dann im Zweifelsfall relativ immer noch.
Besser, weil wenn's denen schlechter geht, dann geht's den anderen noch schlechter. Also es zieht es sozusagen mit sich, ne? Ital
müsste man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen, die ist ja ähnlich wie UK und Spanien äh getroffen hat auch relativ massive äh Einbußen,
nicht ganz so dramatisch wie Spanien und UK. Ich finde das Beispiel UK ganz interessant, weil wenn man sich jetzt mal Italien und Spanien mal rausgreift, okay, die, die hat's ja äh hart getroffen von den Toten her, aber es war dann auch klar, dass sie natürlich als klassische Urlaubsländer,
auch erheblich vom Tourismus äh abhängen. Das mag bei UK nicht ganz so der Fall sein, also nicht, dass da Tourismus keine Rolle spielt.
Sicherlich auch, aber das ist äh.
Nicht ganz so äh ein großes Ding. Trotzdem weit ab äh zurückgeschlagen, was ich mal so ein bisschen noch höre ich nochmal so einen Brexit-Faktor nochmal mit äh einrechnen.
Das könnte bei UK ja dachte ich auch, dass da vielleicht auch noch Brexit mit äh reinspielen könnte. Definitiv,
Ja, aber ähm auf jeden Fall kann man äh.
Aus diesen Zahlen oder aus dieser Grafik definitiv mitnehmen, dass sich Schutz von Gesundheit und Wirtschaft definitiv nicht ausschließen, sondern,
grundsätzlich eher Hand in Hand gehen, eigentlich auch nicht die Überraschung, aber ähm
so ist es dann doch interessant, dass äh tatsächlich äh durch die Zahlen bestätigt zu sehen.
Zumindest also muss man ja so mal einschränken sagen, das bezieht sich jetzt hier auf die äh Zahlen des zweiten Quartals zwanzig zwanzig.
Sicherlich, dass er auch das einzig relevante erstmal jetzt haben wir ja noch September noch abzufeiern, muss man halt mal schauen, wie sich das jetzt im dritten Quartal so entwickelt hat. Im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr,
ne? Das sind jetzt sozusagen hier die Interpretation.
Genau, im Vergleich zum selben Quartal in zweitausendneunzehn. Das äh war sozusagen die.
Die Vergleichszahlen und ja ich also ich rechne damit, dass es da einiges an Bewegung noch
in dieser Grafik geben wird am Ende des Tages, weil das ja gerade im Moment nur eine Zwischenaufnahme
ist und weitere Wellen ja grade hier und da anlaufen und ja und man auch wirtschaftlich.
Sehen wir uns. Wer vielleicht eine langfristige Strategie hat, immer in Deutschland, wurde ja in der Wirtschaft.
Krise, also in der, in der Finanzkrise so ein bisschen durch seine sein Kurzarbeitssystem gerettet, äh so dass dann.
Man relativ schnell wieder durchstarten konnte und,
es mehrn sich auch Expertenstimmen, dass wir wirtschaftlich eher äh so eine äh V-förmige Erholung äh,
haben könnten, was erfreulich ist, also sprich starker Einbruch, aber relativ schnell äh wieder äh eine relativ schnelle Normalisierung.
Der Zahlen äh muss man mal abwarten, aber.
Das ist zumindest äh gerade äh wohl so, dass sich in vielen Ländern die Wirtschaft doch recht schnell zu erholen scheint.
Aber muss man mal abwarten. Natürlich, wie es weitergeht.
Gut. Dann hast du dir noch so ein bisschen ähm die Impfstoffdiskussion äh angeschaut, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Na ja nur ja am Rande also es ist jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Tage äh her.
Dass ich dadrauf äh geguckt hatte,
Ich weiß nicht, hattest du da irgendwie jetzt Punkte die.
Ich hab's auch nicht jetzt tief äh recherchiert. Ich habe so ein paar Artikel äh gelesen. Ich hatte auch ein paar ganz interessante äh Gespräche bei den Hörerinnentreffen, die ich gemacht habe letzte Woche auch so Ärzte dabei so mit unterschiedlichen.
Einschätzung, grundsätzlich scheint so Zurückhaltung äh.
Angesagt zu sein, einfach so ein bisschen auch aus der Frage heraus gut, es sind zwar jetzt viele Impfstoffe unterwegs,
Aber wir wissen halt noch nicht.
Die, die jetzt voran marschieren, ob die Stoffe, die jetzt in der Phase drei sind und die quasi die Kandidaten sind ähm.
Um als erstes auf einen größeren Teil der Bevölkerung äh losgelassen zu werden.
Das sozusagen auch die Impfstoffe sind, die den richtigen Attack-Vektor an der Stelle haben,
Also es gab einen schönen Artikel von äh Lars Fischer bei den äh Siloc, wo er sich speziell über die Frage ähm Gedanken gemacht hat.
Wo denn eigentlich so ein Impfstoff am besten ansetzen sollte.
Und äh so mit dem Aspekt des äh es sich abzeichnet, dass äh.
Menschen ganz gut daran wären, wenn sie quasi diese Antikörperaktivität auch schon in den Schleimhäuten hätten,
das Impfstoffe, die durch so eine Mundmuskel äh Indiktion gegeben werden, sich einfach an Stellen des Körpers einlagern, wo der Virus halt relativ spät hinkommt
wenn er dann erstmal da ist, schon anderer, an anderen Stellen ähm ja sich schon zu sehr
breit gemacht hat oder eben vielleicht auch schon wieder zu äh Infektionen äh führen kann, bevor er so richtig bekämpft ist. Da muss ich jetzt ganz große,
ich bin kein Arzt, ich bin kein
kein Mediziner, also ich habe noch nicht mal ansatzweise irgendeine Kompetenz in diesem Feld, kann das jetzt erstmal nur so nehmen, wie es mir so gesagt wurde, aber da herrscht auf jeden Fall noch eine gewisse Zurückhaltung und vielleicht sollte man daraus ableiten.
Ja okay, Impfstoffe können kommen, aber in dem Moment, wo der erste äh äh den Markt betritt,
ist damit noch erstmal gar nichts gesagt, sondern hängt es mal sehr davon ab, ähm klar, wie gut funktioniert da
lange hält diese Immunität vor und eben auch wie stark hilft diese Immunität auch tatsächlich gegen das Virus.
Ja, also grundsätzlich
Sagen, ich habe mich ja ein bisschen näher vor Jahren mal mit dem äh Immunsystem auseinandergesetzt im Zuge auch äh ja dieser diversen Impfstoff
Debatten vor, ich glaube, weil ich zehn Jahren oder so ähm war die Frage irgendwie ja erzeug,
Impfstoff, Autismus oder wie gefährlich ist das und sind die neuen Impfstoffe und wie die quecksilber enthalten oder Squalene enthalten, also wirkverstärker enthalten äh sind.
Die jetzt äh schlimm und da bin ich mal ein bisschen,
bisschen tiefer in den, in den paar Studien rein und ob auch versucht ansatzweise zu,
wie denn das Immunsystem eigentlich
funktioniert so und wie Impfungen eigentlich funktionieren und der Punkt
komplett eigenen Podcast mitmachen und wahrscheinlich werde ich da auch nicht der richtige äh für aber grundsätzlich so ist das Immunsystem ist einfach der Hammer
Das ist äh einfach mal, ja, da könnte man wahrscheinlich so ein, so ein, so ein richtigen,
Film äh äh drüber drehen mit äh ja verschiedensten Akteuren so. Also es ist ähm,
dass es einen militärisch industrieller Komplex äh.
Allem, äh, was also mit äh mit Patrouillen, die äh äh rumlaufen mit einem komplexen Meldesystem, mit einer Freund Feinderkennung, mit ähm.
Laboren äh also jetzt diese antigene beispielsweise äh wenn wenn die hergestellt,
verehrten. Ähm dann ist das so, dass es ein körpereigene Labore gibt, wo äh die gezüchtet werden,
ausprobiert werden und
dann äh äh und also verschiedene Mutationen veranlasst, äh werden dann geguckt werden, wie gut funktionieren die Dinge und wenn sie nicht gut funktionieren, dann wieder eingestampft äh werden, ja? Das heißt, da gibt's sozusagen eine richtige, ja, eine richtige Waffen
Entwicklung äh so mit äh Tests. So. Außerdem das ist dann eben also ähm,
und es gibt, wir haben praktisch, haben wir zwei Immunsysteme beziehungsweise wir haben halt das angeborene Immunsystem, dass.
Erkennt Viren anhand oder oder schädliche Stoffe so anhand ihres Verhaltens mehr oder weniger und äh.
Reagiert halt sofort, also und dann äh gibt es eben
das andere erworbene Immunsystem, das setzt halt auch auf dem angeborenen an und dirigiert und steuert das, aber das ist sozusagen das, wo Immunität äh entsteht. Und das ist so ein bisschen vielleicht wie beim Rechner, könnte man sagen.
Virusschutz entweder einen ein Programm, was versucht Viren zu erkennen anhand von
allgemeinen Merkmalen von allen Viren während des Erworbene ist halt so ein bisschen äh wo Virussignaturen dann hinterlegt
äh sind und äh wenn dann der Virus wiederkommt, dann weißt das Immunsystem A, OK, das ist der und der Virus und da haben wir jetzt die und die Antikörper für und schmeißen jetzt die Produktion an und das geht dann halt
äh deutlich. Deutlich schneller und äh bis hin dann.
Natürlich zu Prozessen äh also Entzündungsprozesse oder so ähm ist letztlich nichts anderes, dass die die Zell, dass der Zellverbund gelockert wird, damit,
die entsprechenden Stoffe und an die Körper ähm da äh an die Stellen gelangen äh äh können, wo sie hin sollen. Und außerdem gibt es eben auch noch
unterschiedlichste Antikörper für ganz unterschiedliche Milieus, also für für Blut, für
Schleimhäute und ähm ja ähm andere äh Milieus,
hast du halt dann wiederum ja andere Antikörper, die halt anders funktionieren an der Stelle und also
Immunsystem ist halt der absolute Hammer und eine Impfung deswegen,
ist das halt auch so kritisch, also jede äh also erstmal jeder Kontakt mit einer Krankheit verändert das Immunsystem und jede Impfung verändert das Immunsystem dauerhaft.
Heißt ja, du programmierst das um. Und äh das kann halt auch katastrophal schief ge,
ja? Ähm wenn.
Ähm ja und das ist auch nicht rückgängig zu machen. Also Impfung gibt's kein Andu oder so, ja es gibt keine Antiimpfoffe, die äh äh das dann rückgängig machen, sondern
einmal geimpft so und dein Immunsystem ist für immer verändert und da will man natürlich hoffentlich, dass es nur so verändert wird, dass es äh halt auf,
die gewünschten äh Erreger äh reagiert. Aber es kann natürlich alles Mögliche, andere schiefgehen und deswegen testet man.
Natürlich die Dinger ohne Ende und auch wenn du Millionen Menschen impfen willst, dann kommt es natürlich immer zu Impfschäden,
so irgendwelche Leute sind halt immer irgendwie halt entweder gesundheitlich in einem entsprechenden Zustand.
Oder ja haben halt einen Organismus, der einfach nicht in nicht normal,
ist und nicht normal reagiert, aber das, aber du willst natürlich bei einem Impfstoff, dass das möglichst
wenig sind, also das ist irgendwie unter, wenn du eine Million Leute impfst, du wirst nicht ein Prozent oder null Komma ein Prozent, sondern du willst halt ganz viele,
Nullen hinter dem Komma haben äh bei der Prozentzahl von Leuten ähm die das Ganze dann nicht vertragen oder die davon geschäd.
Werden und deswegen also diese einerseits diese Komplexität so und die.
Impfstoff, wie gesagt, die greifen jetzt auch nicht, also es ist nicht so, dass dass da dann irgendein Stoff, dass der Impfstoff dann irgendwie im Körper verbleibt und irgendwas tut, sondern was der Impfstoff hier tut, ist eben dein Immunsystem umzubauen. Ja
Ähm und äh ja das ist halt das Ding äh mit mit,
Impfungen und weswegen ich.
Auch glaube, dass das noch eine ganze Weile dauern kann, weil du äh es geht halt stückweise. Man,
diese Phasenmodelle so erst äh im Computer und äh dann in Zellkulturen und dann an irgendwelchen Versuchstieren und dann äh wird am Menschen getestet und am Menschen, dann
zu natürlich zum einen überhaupt auch Verträglichkeit aber dann auch auf Wirksamkeit, weil auch wieder einen Impfstoff, wo die Hälfte der Leute oder zwei Drittel keine richtige ordentliche Immunität erlangt
ist natürlich auch nicht äh das, was man haben
wild ähm wird's halt eine gute spezifische, langfristige Immunisierung äh ohne
möglichst ohne Nebenwirkungen und.
Deswegen dauert das halt in der Regel ein paar Jahre.
Genau, deswegen dauert das halt Jahre und verschlingt Milliarden und ganz viele Kandidaten stellt man fest, dass die dann halt auch nicht funktionieren. Und äh Jörg.
Also.
Von daher, wie gesagt, ich rechne auch eher beim letzten Mal frühestens im Laufe des nächsten Jahres äh,
mit äh einer Impfung und dann kommt noch dazu, selbst wenn man den dann hat, muss der natürlich in größerer Zahl produziert werden. Da
dauert auch, also wir haben nicht die Kapazitäten, um jetzt Milliarden an Dosen oder selbst hunderte Millionen von von Dosen in kürzester Zeit zu produzieren
sondern je nachdem was für ein Impfstoffkandidat das ist kann das auch mehr oder weniger aufwendig sein.
Das Ganze. Ja und der russische Impfstoff in dem Zusammenhang ähm.
Weil angeblich hat Putin ja seine Tochter damit äh impfen lassen.
Hat er gesagt, eine eine seiner Töchter, ich weiß nicht, wie viel er hat, aber davor war die R.
Genau und ähm.
Alles so ein so ein bisschen wie japanische Minister, der dann Fukushima Wasser getrunken hat oder wer war das damals noch der durch den Rhein geschwommen ist.
Gott, ja und ein Minister.
Etwas lustige mit der Borille äh hieß er.
Blühen, ja, ne? Ich glaube, das war's, ich meine es äh ich meine es, wäre blühen gewesen, aber ich kann mich, kann mich auch irren äh äh ja. Ähm.
Ja, also und.
Äh gut diese dieser Impfstoff ist jetzt so in die Kritik geraten, weil wohl die Zahlen irgendwie verdächtig aussehen und.
Das es war war zwar,
Gibt's zwar einen Pierre Reviewen Artikel, aber der wurde halt äh da wurden halt offensichtlich noch nicht die die kompletten Rohdaten äh äh rausgegeben und die Daten, die.
Bei dem Artikel dabei waren, haben halt irgendwelche Statistiker.
Gesagt, die sehen zu sauber aus. Das ist äh echte Daten sehen nicht so sauber aus.
Klaus Töpfer hat den Rhein.
Ach Töpfer, Töpfer war's.
Ja ja, der damaliger Bundesumweltminister neben Lügen war ja irgendwie schon immer eher für sozial.
Genau, ja, ja, nee, dann habe ich habe ich die beiden irgendwie was töpfer. Ich glaube, der hat einen ganz schlimmen Ausschlag gekriegt danach oder.
Ja, aber es war wohl eine verlorene Wette, also irgendwie.
Okay.
Auf jeden Fall war so äh Ende der achtziger Jahre.
Ja ähm ja also wie gesagt Impfstoffe ja.
Wird irgendwann kommen, aber äh aber wahrscheinlich irgendwann kommen, aber äh eher eher nicht dieses Jahr,
und eher nicht vor der Wahl,
läuft ja gerade auch der Streit so, weil irgendwie auch Trumps aktuell neuer Chef, äh der CDC oder so äh ihm direkt widersprochen hat äh und äh
Ja, war dann.
Soll man auch anderes tun bei Trump.
Ja und Trump meinte er sei verwirrt. Der Typ ähm.
Ja, das meinen wir ja auch alle von Trump,
Gut, das äh bringt uns ein bisschen ans Ende äh der Sendung. Ich habe mich gerade gefragt, wie man so ein bisschen aus äh klingen sollte jetzt gerade äh bei deinem recht pessimistisch äh ähm.
Ja
Blick auf die Infroph Situation, wie man jetzt sozusagen mit dem Herbst äh klarkommen soll. Ich denke, grundsätzlich haben wir das Besteck schon in der Hand.
Und es heißt einfach Masken tragen. Und ich spüre auch langsam hier mein subjektiver Eindruck, Prenzlauer Berg, ja.
Äh die Akzeptanz ist da.
Sagen wir mal so, die Normalität ist da. Also ich mag's an verschiedenen Faktoren ähm auch so Läden, die sich bisher immer gesperrt hatten.
Setzen das jetzt auch mehr durch und ne, es gibt natürlich immer so ein paar Ausreißer äh gerade so an Sportstätten.
Squash-Hallen,
wo dann irgendwie mal so die Frage ist, ja wo setzt man überhaupt auf? Ja klar auf einen Court irgendwie äh äh nicht so, aber dann hast du davor immer noch so einen losen Gastrobereich, wo du dann irgendwie zwei Stunden lang an deinem Bier nitten kannst, so
offiziell auch keine tragen muss, aber wenn er zehn Meter weiter äh an der Anmeldung stehst, dann musst du auf jeden Fall eine anhaben
was halt auch wir auch alles so ein bisschen absurd ist und dann Umkleideräume, ne, so Dusche
äh da sind die Übergänge so fließend und äh die Piercresher ist glaube ich noch nicht so hart, weil alle auch immer so ein bisschen Angst haben, die anderen glaube ich so ein bisschen.
Nerven oder irgend so eine Überreaktion vielleicht auch zu erzeugen oder so. Trotz Reaktionen.
Ja.
So ein bisschen so eine negative Auswirkung von dieser ganzen Corona äh Leugner-Fraktion ist. Ähm, trotzdem.
Merke ich auch an mir selber, wie wie diese Automatik immer mehr da ist.
Irgendwo rein und du weißt einfach, wenn du durch eine Tür gehst, hast du eine Maske auf so und.
Mhm.
Dass das kann schon auch äh noch ein bisschen ansteigen. Ein bisschen skeptisch bin ich, was so Kneipen und sowas betrifft, da tummeln sich äh glaube ich viele Leute, die so ein bisschen drauf scheißen.
Ist kein Bock drauf haben sich noch weiter einschränken zu lassen, weiß nicht, ist ein irgendwie so ein merkwürdiger äh äh Fatalismus, da tut's mir dann so ein bisschen um die Leute leid, die halt da arbeiten müssen. Ja und ansonst.
Also jetzt was ich so gesehen habe auch äh gerade jetzt natürlich in der sozusagen die letzten,
möglicherweise letzten warmen Tage war der Andrang äh äh draußen gewaltig, also so äh.
Kneipen und Restaurants waren rappelvoll so.
Und ähm ja teilweise dann eben auch äh mich Leute aus verschiedenen Gruppen, die dann an Tischen zusammen äh saßen und so und Abstände, hm.
Ja, also hey, das äh ja äh,
sei jetzt, aber grundsätzlich ja, kann man sagen, ich meine, was, was ich mache, auch also im,
Innenraum Maske auf oder wenn man kein Abstand halten kann, Maske auf so und äh ja ansonsten nach Möglichkeit, sich mit,
fremden Leuten nur draußen mit.
Hinreichend Abstand treffen und äh möglichst bei Wind äh auch und für den, ja, für den Herbst habe ich jetzt noch nicht so auch richtig die.
Lösung, äh wenn sich dann mehr Dinge nach innen verlagern, aber muss man halt durch äh ja.
Sollte ja nicht so das Problem sein im Herbst. Halbwegs halbwegs normalen Saisonverlauf haben, was ja nun auch nicht äh gerade gesagt ist so und dann äh ja, Winter wird dann natürlich wieder ein totales Einschließen und isolieren.
Ja.
Wobei man natürlich ja die Heizpilzdebatte natürlich äh losgegangen ist äh jetzt auch, ob man nicht versucht, dann mit Hilfe von Heizpilzen jetzt, dass draußen so ein bisschen zu verlängern und
auch wenn mich ein paar Leute dafür hassen werden, aber so ich wäre absolut dafür
ähm so sagen das zu tun zumal tatsächlich auch der.
Energiebedarf oder jetzt speziell so bei Gasbetriebenen äh sagen Außenheizung, ja. Die sind jetzt nicht effizient, aber.
So ein ähm.
Ein großer, nicht zwei oder drei KW-Gasbrenner läuft mit einer Gasflasche sechs bis zehn Stunden lang und setzt dabei so viel CO2 frei wie
eine Stunde Autofahr.
Also von daher ja finde ich ähm so ja für eine Stunde weniger Autofahren, kann man irgendwie zehn Stunden lang.
Außen.
Oder einfach das Steak kein Steak essen, dann hast du dein CO zwei äh.
Verbrauch auch schon wieder äh ausreichend eingeschränkt so, also ich glaube, das sind so die anderen Faktoren an dem man drehen kann. Ja, ist eine schwierige äh Debatte, Zurückhaltung haben wir ja nun schon einiges äh geübt äh wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr Zurückhaltung gefragt.
Ähm ja ansonsten ja mal nur sagt vorsichtig.
Weiter vorsichtig bleiben und ich habe eigentlich auch wirklich keine Lust äh.
Mir das Ganze einzufangen, so weil ich äh eigentlich nach dem, was man hört auf jeden Fall auch zur Risikogruppe gehören dürfte.
Als übergewichtiger Raucher.
Ja, die Raucherstudie hat sich bestätigt.
Nee, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung äh.
Habe ich auch nichts viel davon gehört so, das wäre doch mal ganz interessant. Wo sind denn überhaupt die ganzen verrückten, lustigen Studien irgendwie rund um Corona, wo man mal äh herzlich drüber lachen kann? Da ist auf jeden Fall noch einiges zu holen.
Ah ja, ja, ich bin neulich auf eine gestoßen.
Sogar auf den WHO-Seiten, das ist sogar eine richtige Studie, wo über den extrateristische Herkunft äh äh des Corona Virus.
Das.
Spekuliert wurde. Ja ja.
Ernsthaft? Mhm.
Die Studie ist von von Februar, also äh da.
Aber ist halt eine ernsthafte Studie äh über ja das äh sagen der Virus auf uns herabgeregnet ist aus dem Weltall.
Wie er dort entstanden ist und warum und so lässt der Artikel sich jetzt nicht weiter äh äh drüber aus, aber ja, das war so ein bisschen die absurdest äh äh Stu.
Das war die Schlussfolgerung, dass er von da kommt oder was? Der außerirdische Virus.
Dass das äh äh sagen Corona, dass der Corona Virus außerirdischen Ursprungs äh ist.
Der Virus. Oh Mann, aus dem Ei.
Zu sagen genau und dann auf bestimmte Länder eben besonders herab geregnet äh ist und die waren dann eben deswegen besonders betroffen, weil.
Da halt besonders viel Virus runtergekommen ist. Ja, aber wie gesagt, jetzt keine, also das ist jetzt kein.
Scheint jetzt kein Artikel von irgendwelchen verrückten Cranks zu sein, sondern nur von von echten verrückten Wissenschaftlern.
Ja, auch nicht besser.
Gut Pavel, dann würde ich sagen ähm machen wir vielleicht in zwei Wochen nochmal einen Aufwasch äh mit den ganzen Zahlen. Bisher eh glaube ich ein bisschen unterwegs und dann gucken wir mal, wie's äh so weitergeht hier mit unserer.
Ise und bis dahin bleiben wir einfach wacker. Ne? Gut, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, wir sagen tschüss und.
Tschüs.